[MUSIC]
Well let's take the case where you're
a manager and you don't feel like
you have the capacity or maybe you
don't have the shared language.
It sometimes happens that people
there's a fork in your career and
over time you become less
technical as a manager.
That doesn't block your empathy,
so you can see and
hear what your team is struggling with.
So I think often it's enough to create a
space in which experimentation is okay,
it's safe.
I don't want to dig too deeply
into the psychology of managing in
the text space, but I will say this.
Both the goal and the role of
a management position inside of in
tech today is one of supporting
teams and team learning.
So you can just take the approach of
my role here is to create a space
in which this team can learn its way
out of the pain that it sees and
that is often enough.
Could you add money?
Could you add resources?
Sure and
you should at every responsible moment.
But prior to that, you just need to
encourage a strong culture of learning.
As a manager I think your
primary role especially early
is to create a culture of learning to
to make it sort of safe and open for
people to experiment and learn.